This gets done sometimes,
in medical imaging.
So here is a, an old scan.
Probably a, I'm going to guess CT.
And the image on the left
is the grayscale,
and then they've thresholded
the image on the right.
And what you'd like to do is,
you'd like to say, you know,
there's this chunk here, and
there's this chunk there, and
maybe this chunk, and this chunk,
and some things there, and that.
And maybe I'm going to ignore
some of that other stuff.
The first thing that we're going to
look at is what's referred to as
a connected component analysis,
all right?
So some of these
are a little hard to see.
But we'll just focus on
this one right here.
The idea is I'd like to pull out this
thing as being distinct say from this
thing, okay?
These are not connected so, I would
like to label this maybe as a 2 and
this as a 3, all right because I want to
find all of the connected components.
Or connected set of pixels.
The connected components algorithm or
operation takes a binary image and
it generates what's referred
to as labelled image.
So every pixel now it used to be a 0 1,
it's now giving it a label
that is the number of
the object to which it belongs.
So right, if there is just one object,
everything will be a 0 or 1 and
the 1, right?
But if there are two objects,
there'll be 0s, 1s and 2s.
All right, by the way, one of the things
that we're not going to talk about is
when we talk about a pixel being
connected to another pixel,
there's what's known as 4-way
connected and 8-way connected.
4-way means that you're connected
to north, south, east, and west.
Did I get those right?
Well, it depends upon
which way you're looking.
8-way connected, says I'm connected
to the north, south, east, west, and
I'm connected to northeast, northwest,
southeast, southwest, all right?
For what I'm going to show you here,
we're going to assume a 4-way connected
the, the algorithm is pretty
much the same if it's 8-way.